what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of gq recommends
today we're going to be walking you
through how to wear sandals which ones
to buy and three categories that are
really worth your time the dress sandal
closed toe mule and the classics
[Music]
the dress sandals
first of all they're mostly going to be
made out of leather they're probably
going to have a metal buckle and they're
going to feel heftier and more
substantial all around so they're going
to feel in your hand and on your foot
more like a loafer or a dress shoe so
it's probably not a shock to hear that
like these types of sandals were super
popular in the 60s and 70s they've been
having a serious resurgence and
i really dig them because they are
doused in retro vibes you'll kind of
feel like a hollywood a-lister from like
the 70s who's vacationing off the amalfi
coast it's a great vibe to indulge in i
like dress sandals i'm wearing a pretty
dressy pair of fisherman sandals right
now there is an element of
casualness to a sandal obviously by
nature and it's kind of a cool paradox
to pair your sandals with the suit
haraches are a super traditional shoe
they have that level of pliable comfort
but they also cover the entirety of your
foot so your toes aren't exposed if you
have any hang-ups about that so you want
to be a little bit careful when you buy
a pair of harachi's because there are a
lot of brands making
slightly shoddier versions that won't
hold up for very long
solo is a cool brand because it's based
in the u.s but it actually owns its own
factories in peru close to the area
where the hirachi originated and the
quality lasts so the next pair that
we're going to talk about are from
grenson which is an english storage shoe
brand that actually makes the pair of
sandals i'm wearing right now and the
difference between these and the
hirachi's is hirachi's by definition
tend to be a much slimmer silhouette
so they're a little bit dainty this is
not this is a decidedly chunky
silhouette with a fairly massive ripple
sole that you can see here so if you
have an outfit that you would normally
wear like a pair of docks or a hearty
pair of derbies with you can swap these
in instead and you'll look far more
summer ready
what's cool about these sandals which
are from camper when you think of
sandals at least leather ones you might
think of a pretty traditional gladiator
sandal this is almost like a freakified
riff on it because it's got that chunky
sole again and it has the ridged leather
but it doesn't extend far up the leg and
it's an altogether far more streamlined
silhouette if you're wondering where you
would wear a dress sandal you can
definitely wear one with all the normal
things you would wear a dressier shoe
with like a suit or a button down and
trousers but i also think they look
really cool with like a pair of cut off
jean shorts and a flowy button down and
just like a tank top and a simple gold
chain
there's a reason they've been around so
long and it's because they're timeless
they're not going anywhere they're a
safe investment you can wrap your head
around the idea of buying a sandal that
you'll actually wear to dressier
occasions start with one of these
mule is basically a sandal that is
closed at the toe but open at the back
it's as simple as that yules are huge
right now and who's to say why there's
probably myriad reasons all sorts of
different factors that are working
together to contribute to their rise
first up let's talk about these
absolutely absurd mules from prada they
come in the full rainbow spectrum of
hues they're made out of this
really sleek
almost matte rubber they're super
comfortable if i had to pick one pair of
mules pop off in the nba tunnel when the
season starts next season it would
definitely be these prada joints these
are not a viable dress sandal
alternative i have a feeling that if you
have the money to buy a pair of these
you're probably pretty comfortable
wearing them around the house as a shoe
that you don't do anything other than
get the mail or run the bodega in
but they would also look really cool
with like a pair of baggy flare jeans
and like a fuzzy striped cardigan
super cozy vibes but
again if you're looking for a pretty
splashy logo hit these will definitely
do the trick marnie's take on the
silhouette is much sleeker and a little
bit more discreet because it's cut from
this kind of handsome pebbled grain
leather
type of material you might see on a pair
of brogues or more high-end dress shoe
which i think makes it way more
versatile and also way more conducive to
dressing up i would wear these with like
a super slouchy suit and like a
threadbare white tee honestly like if if
you're familiar with isumiyaki and you
like the the pleats pants that he makes
you should buy the jacket version too
throw on like a uniqlo u
box fresh white tea and just a pair of
these and you're set if you're looking
for a pair of sandals that you can
pretty reliably wear almost year-round
if you're a die-hard sandal enthusiast
looking for a way to get the most wear
out of your favorite pair of shoes
mule is a solid way to do it so
birkenstock basically makes two pairs of
shoes that it's most famous for and that
we would consider essentials the arizona
and the boston which are the mules that
we're holding right here they come in a
bunch of different styles a bunch of
different colors most people probably
don't think of birkenstocks and the
boston in particular as a formal shoe
but the leather kind of gives it an
element of polish
that you could conceivably wear with a
suit seth rogen is a big fan of
birkenstocks he wears them with more
casual fare like t-shirts and chinos but
he's also been known to rock
birkenstocks or birkenstock s
silhouettes on the red carpet the reason
why it's such a staple of so many
people's closet is because it's a pretty
great rounded toe that's bulky but not
overly cumbersome
[Music]
the last pair we're going to talk about
in this category is the reebok beat knit
which is a super popular mule style
that's just about everywhere right now
and for good reason
so there's a few things to call out
about this particular mule first of all
it's got that telltale padded strap in
the back there's no uncomfortable fabric
jostling for real estate with your ankle
it's got a quilted upper which is super
comfortable and also deceptively sturdy
and it has that zigzag almost ripple
like sole at the bottom really
comfortable durable great as a house
shoe but definitely one like the
birkenstock that you can wear out of the
house as well if you want to rock these
as a more traditional mole you totally
have the option you can just simply flip
up the strap and leave them as is i
think i like them better with the strap
down but the functionality is there if
you choose to wear them like that
i would call like diplo a modern day
freaky mule connoisseur i don't think
he's met a weird meal that he doesn't
like he really doesn't discriminate when
it comes to where he wears his mules
he'll wear them anywhere which is how a
good pair of mules should be treated no
matter how much you paid for them this
is a great example because it's it's the
benefit of what a mule has to offer in
one outfit so diplo could have easily
worn a pair of sneakers here
but because he's wearing a mule it adds
this sort of like
rolled out of bed
don't really care
but everything else still looks pulled
together and the mule is a huge
component
[Music]
we're going to walk you through a few
classic styles that will never steer you
wrong well we're starting with
birkenstocks because they're kind of the
first name in the sandal game they've
been around in one form or another since
the late 1700s
but their signature style the one that
you probably recognize that you're
looking at right here is the arizona
that was introduced more recently in the
early 1970s birkenstocks are
specifically engineered to be
comfortable so they'll offer all the
support you need for whatever you're
doing this summer and beyond it
shouldn't be a surprise that bob weir
wears birkenstocks he wears them all the
time very consistently
but you don't have to be a rock and roll
legend to pull them off their
versatility naturally lends themselves
to a bunch of different styles so you
have people like devin booker who's
somewhere in italy in a very tonal
all-white fit and he looks fantastic
then you also have people like chris
pine who pairs his with
slim dark jeans and looks equally great
too so if you'll notice also both of
these fellas are wearing pants which
might seem a little bit unusual if
you're wearing sandals as well
but the good thing about sandals
nowadays is that you can actually wear
them with pants and birkenstocks will
look cool whether you're wearing them
with shorts
loungy linen pants or slim dark denim
teva has been around since the early 80s
and they initially got their start
catering to
people who are outdoors a lot
and tend to spend most of the day on
their feet the second you feel them you
can tell that they have a really springy
footbed but the footbed is also backed
up with a vibram sole which is like the
first name in high quality footwear
finishing so you're getting really solid
traction and a super durable finish for
not a ton of money and they're going to
help you stay comfortable no matter
where you wear them so like birkenstock
they've got a lot of functional
bonafides but now they've also sort of
elevated themselves into the realm of
high fashion and for good reason they
look pretty sick there's this growing
realization that everything can be a
fashion item if you style it the right
way or if you style it in a way that
feels distinct to you so a perfect
example of this would be a guy like
tyler the creator who's
far and away one of the most stylish
dudes on the planet and he routinely
wears these with outfits you would
normally wear with a pair of sneakers or
loafers and he looks sick he wears baggy
cuff denim and white socks
or a puffer jacket even which seems like
a paradox but he consistently pulls it
off because he doesn't treat them like
sandals he treats them like any other
shoe in his rotation socks and sandals
it's a contentious topic personally i'm
all for it i really only ever wear my
sandals with socks and it's not because
i have gross feet socks and sandals is a
dope combination i think that it looks
super fresh it's a little bit unexpected
it feels counter-intuitive because it
kind of is you're almost negating the
point of allowing your toes to feel the
breeze by swaddling them in a pair of
socks
nike which as you probably know is like
the first name in performance gear
elevated it to its logical conclusion it
makes a super trail ready sandal that
kind of builds on what teva helped
establish
and then levels it up considerably with
a bulky ridge sole and this bungee pull
tab here that lends it all a very
technical gorp-oriented finish first and
foremost these look sick that's always
the most important component in my
opinion the sole that you have here is
ridge it has a ton of durability and
traction
you'll be able to scale whatever peaks
you encounter and overall look really
good doing it
so if you have a few more dollars to
spend on a pair of sandals that is super
celeb loved in fact and suey coke is a
great option they're a japanese brand
made with really high quality materials
and they look great too it's kind of
like a nice middle ground between the
teva and the nike model that we were
talking about because you get a lot of
the same functionality there's that
vibram soul again there though it's it's
slightly different than the one that
teva uses they feel more elevated and
and they feel that way too like if you
hold them in your hand they've got more
heft to them so they're not as
lightweight as a pair of tevas but
they're slightly dressier than the nikes
that we were looking at earlier so the
next silhouette that we're going to be
talking about are slides which you're
probably familiar from your dorm room
days or from the myriad fancy versions
that people like kanye west at yeezy
make now
but the pair that i'm going to talk
about today is from camper what i think
is cool about them is that they have a
hefty ridge sole not unlike some of the
more trail ready options we were talking
about earlier
but they have these criss-crossing
straps right here that are made out of a
super sturdy cotton twill you can see
it's kind of a nubby pattern
and they're really handsome overall i
really dig this pair in in the cotton
twill but they also come in leather
which is a really cool move if you're
trying to dress up your sandals which
yes is something you can definitely do
sandals have been around for a long time
and the silhouette that people have been
wearing for for decades
centuries maybe looks a whole lot like
this when we're talking about classic
sandals these are about as classic as
you can get
[Music]
all right guys that's it for today thank
you very much for tuning in and
hopefully we answered
some of the questions you have about
what sandals to buy and how to wear them
i think my personal favorite was
probably one of the suey coke pairs that
we referenced earlier in the classic
section if you liked any of the pairs we
talked about today be sure to check out
the links in the description below
they're all going to be right there for
you thanks for watching gq recommends
and as always catch you on the next
episode